[Music]
so the and rental agreement didn't even
have any like written contracts I think
that just because a buddy of ours it's
like the head of the marketing
department over there so as I can a
verbal agreement that's we're gonna do
August 4th of 12 we're gonna come in and
shoot certain videos and they're gonna
post them throughout the week so it's
gonna be like daily edits we were we
were under the depression that was gonna
be like one video per day okay kind of
thing so then when the dates got closer
so he has this lady working under him
won't mention her name but I think she
he kind of gets her to run everything
like organize everything and plan
everything out so as we started shooting
she started becoming really unreasonable
so she'd start demanding like three
videos shot and then edited on the same
day so we'd be with them all day from
like morning 9 a.m. we probably finished
with him at 9 p.m. get home and the two
hours later she's asking where these
videos are and then when we get when we
see her in person she's also being like
very sarcastic and condescending being
very disrespectful yeah it just got to a
point where we couldn't take any more we
felt like we were being no like talked
down to we weren't being respected so
then kinda had a talk and we said is
this even worth the money should we just
walk away from this right now there's a
lot of money probably the biggest
contract we've ever had okay so we do
suffer with it for another week or do we
just leave the leave the money behind
and have respect for ourselves as a
company for me what I'm thinking about
is not so much to money but the
reputation yeah how important is your
reputation
whenever there's a whenever there's a
disagreement with a client or supplier I
always try to leave on a positive always
like even though I have to eat
everything I try to I try to I try to
make me feel good like I would try to
find something I think I think people
need to be came with a new thing today
chief goal officer I think you have to
be people's chief goal officer what did
she want
what's her goal what did she want in her
company forget about screwing like
screwing you guys over it might be her
globe right now you're not gonna help
that you know how to help that you could
help that but that doesn't help you so
what's her what's her bigger goal how
can you make her look good what is what
is her outcome what's our goal like for
me when you tell me your goal what's
it's dangerous because I want to help
you whether it's you calling the girl or
messaging her and your dad and your your
movie like I want to know your goals
because it it's just I love it feeds me
but that's what you should be she-beast
people's chief goal officer this won't
mind what is that whatever goals of this
company for this event what does she
want it's not just making three videos
and XYZ it's like what what is the
outcome for her out of this and how can
you help provide it even if it has
nothing to do with video like maybe
something totally outside the box you
can even make it to that she's happy
even if you don't give her what she
wants just by the relationship and
communication like some people just
don't know right like you part of your
business educating what your process
looks like I don't know what's possible
like is this gonna be up tonight no but
I write I get it
so she didn't leave that first encounter
feeling great about de-evolve she might
not have want you to jump off a bridge
like she might now but she didn't want
you get it yeah right she wasn't feeling
great it might be as simple as buying
her coffee in the morning
no but like you never know it but to
make somebody like you
it it might be as something as simple as
like being friendly and not that you
guys are not friendly but doing
something yeah small could make a huge
impact in a good fuel that all the rest
of this would never have happened - same
thing with your buddy what's his goal
what does he want from this
what are his metrics for promotion he
wants promotion word of his metrics how
are they measuring him as soon as I know
what the metrics are I went to an event
with sage my first my first ever
speaking gig with sage there metric was
Twitter impressions like we wanted we
want to get promotion how you measuring
it there KPI key performance indicator
Twitter impressions so how many views
and you did it by how many people were
watching or how many tweets went out
times how many followers that person had
said well what do you what are your
goals we want to get 2 million
impressions by the end of the conference
2 million I had a hundred thousand
followers yourself into the time I'll
get you that myself I just tweeted like
two hundred times using their hashtags
where the math is and I give them I gave
them their metric just me and then I got
hired for a three-year deal right like
again this is stupid like that's gonna
be how you measure it that's that's how
they define it great I want to make you
look good
he could go then take it to his boss and
say look we crushed the numbers you
wanted this here's we we came in at so
he wants promotion what does that look
like again whether you don't have to
ever work with them again if you don't
like the woman it never turns out the
guy is a douchebag whatever you just
never want to take a project okay look
but like the thing that you make needs
to be amazing to help them like it's
work you're proud of and helps them
accomplish their goals where if you're
just doing it for the money you just
give them what they want and it goes out
it's like okay that sucks like putting
in your portfolio did you make something
that you want to put in your portfolio
and say I'm proud of what I did here
probably not and so that's when that's
when you start to
feel soul-sucking on top of the bad
relationships but like the work you do
should be something that you want to put
in your portfolio you need to come out
feeling like you did like you're proud
of the work that you did I want all I
want you guys to grow I want sage to
grow like every company that I touch I
want to grow and I'm gonna give every I
may not always give them a result but
like I'm trying I'm trying my best to
give them the result when you're just
going after money you don't put the
effort in as much and then you never end
up growing because they likely don't
want to bring you back or you're just
the default option and they don't want
to do the work because they have bigger
problems somewhere else that they have
to deal with you never get referrals
from it you're stuck doing work that
does not something you're proud of and
that's the cycle a lot of entrepreneurs
get stuck in so the other thing we
talked about is being pushovers and we
thought that maybe just laying low
laying down letting her taking a beating
from this lady it's not gonna be good
for us in the long term because it's
gonna get us used to just taking the
beatings from every other client instead
of
standing up for ourselves as a company
yeah so again it starts with you
catching the signals and understanding
and like now she's in your mind every
time we're going into another deal so
she's hopefully giving you more
emotional intelligence so that you don't
even get into those situations again
where you have to not be a pushover
right like step one to then is just
having the honest conversations from a
from a trying not to be massively
frustrated place where I like okay to do
this we'll need to do this like that in
order to do this we'll have to take away
from here because it takes eight hours
to edit a video or she might not be
thinking that if you're taking on a job
then you do like you committed to that
job even if you over commit it to it
like you take in on a wedding like make
it the best wedding video of all time
like that you should be proud of the
it's not where you want to be yet but
this is a stepping stone to get to where
you want to go if you're not doing it
for yourself if you're not enjoying the
thing that you're making like the the
work you still get to control how you
get treated around and your schedule but
like the work the editing you get to
control the final product gets put out
and yes they may have employee and say
hey don't feature the loss and don't pop
up right but within the constraints you
still get the control it's there's a way
that you can be passion super proud of
the thing that you may I don't care I'm
not focused on the money I'm not focused
on like my how my ego has been brew
I'm being disrespected now if it's if
it's a long-term thing absolute like do
I ever want to look these guys again no
like something I have to massively
change who me to ever want to take that
deal again I know it's for one week I'm
gonna make the best of it I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna trick myself into
believing that this is awesome this is
my chance to prove myself and I need to
deliver an amazing piece of work that
I'm proud of the work I can then use
that company's name to help me people
get more work but I'm not doing it
because I'm afraid of losing money it's
not a good reason to be in the situation
I'm not doing because they they're mean
to me or they offended or bruised my ego
right like I try to in the moment of
being overwhelmed and being feeling like
I'm being disrespected I try to have I
try to just have empathy like how how
how crappy does their life have to be
right now she may be a terrible person
she's extra terrible now because of
everything that's going on this is a big
deal for them and I'm coming in the
middle
I want to make their lives easier so I
probably never work for them
again unless something major changes and
I think that's a good barometer for
clients that you work with just
understanding do I trust this person
enough that I want to look with them
forever like these guys no it's fine
there's stepping-stone to something else
you're gonna leverage their name you're
proud of the work you did I just don't
want people leaving a relationship
feeling that I didn't do my part I was
like them feeling like I did a great job
even if it means have to do crazy over
and above and I'm gone crazy I'm above a
lot of times our clients that have
worked with even when I shouldn't know
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people your passion and not one drop of
myself work depends on your it's
supposed to mean if you know what your
goals are but you're afraid to go after
them because of other people's judgments
check out the video right next to me I
think it's gonna help you continue to
believe and I'll see you there
people aren't afraid of failing they're
afraid of failing in front of other
people right I think people are so
worried about other people's judgment
that they don't even try